bonsoir et bienvenue sur tv fil 78 pour
le 7-8 une heure pour faire le point sur
l'actualité locale en direct jusqu'à 19h
premiers invités sont dits descoings
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes la
coordinatrice événementielle de la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines dans deux
jours samedi soir saint quentin en
yvelines va participer à la nuit blanche
la manifestation existe depuis 2002 sur
paris sur la ville de paris pourquoi
avoir décidé de de participer de s'y
joindre justement une envie de
concurrencer ce qui se faisait sur paris
pas du tout une envie de concurrence une
envie de proposer des choses différentes
à saint quentin en yvelines au départ
l'idée venue d'animer la médiathèque du
canal différemment de la montrer au
public différemment ou que ce qu'on a
fait il ya trois ans de ça et donc les
choses ont avancé progresser cette année
pour les 40 ans de l'agglomération
on se retrouve implanté donc dans le
quartier 17 mar avec la mobilisation de
l'ensemble des structures culturelles et
de l'association des commerçants et
aussi des amateurs qui font partie eux
aussi des amateurs tout à fait opposés
on va regarder le programme en détail
tout à l'heure ce soir nous parlerons
aussi économie la chronique aequo avec
alice gastineau fois résidence à wilfrid
alors ce soir j'ai choisi de
m'intéresser à une école un qui est basé
à versailles qui n'est pas très connu
mais qui moi m'a interpellé c'est
l'école de l'intelligence économique
alors c'est quoi alors ça m'a justement
on va voir pendant une vingtaine de
minutes avec son directeur qui sera en
plateau puis nous ferons un point aussi
sur le secteur de l'automobile puisque
il ya une ombre débrayage notamment à
renault fluence la chronique échos du
jeudi aux alentours de 18 heures 20 si
vous nous suivez donc en direct le reste
du sommaire de ce 4 octobre en images
avec une situation est sous tension du
côté de flins en plein mondial de l'auto
en plein lancement de la clio iv et de
la zoé et des syndicalistes de
l'entreprise renault étaient mobilisés
cet après midi pour dénoncer des
conditions de travail qui se dégradent
et des manques d'effectifs une prise de
parole est l'une devant l'usiné
elle est dangers du cannabis en cinq ans
la consommation de cannabis chez les
jeunes a augmenté de 60% des données
alarmantes et qui pousse les
professionnels à organiser des réunions
de sensibilisation est les médecins de
l'hôpital charcot de plaisir viennent
d'en organiser une vous le verrez tout à
l'heure un atelier d'arts plastiques
pour personnes en situation de handicap
cela se déroule dans les locaux de
l'association des paralysés de france à
voisins le bretonneux vous rencontrerez
ce soir ghislaine qui découvrent la
linogravure et puis sachez que les
filles du club de tennis de table d'élan
cours ont bien entamé leur saison elles
ont battu à domicile l'équipe de
mulhouse à l'issue de parties très
accroché la colère qui gronde donc du
côté de flins pas de grève mais une
mobilisation des syndicats qui
dénonçaient cet après midi les
conditions de travail dans cette usine
appartenant à renault les explications
d'anthony rech
avec le lancement de la nouvelle renault
clio iv et de la zoé la voiture
électrique de la marque le rendement de
l'usiné de flins augmente mais les
salariés sont confrontés à un manque
d'effectifs selon les syndicats présents
aux portes du centre ce jeudi midi on
est en colère parce que il faut si on
veut fabriquer correctement des voitures
il faut du personnel et entre les gars
qui morfle sur les chaînes etc d'un côté
et ceux qui morfle du chômage à côté
c'est inadmissible et du coup ça s'est
exprimée vraiment par des arrêts de
travail ce matin pour contraindre la
direction à prendre l'effectif suffisant
encore ce matin et une heure et demi
d'arrêt de travail des caristes pour
réclamer du personnel supplémentaire
parce que ils n'arrivent pas à décharger
les camions ils n'arrivent pas à mettre
les pièces là où il faut et c'est les
salariés de renault flins se rendront
mardi 9 octobre pour manifester au
mondial de l'automobile avant de se
joindre à un cortège nationale à l'appel
des syndicats européens